this is dire Safiye and Sunday are your
prime days for business but like many
failing restaurants sherita's making
some classic mistakes poor man's meat
pie yeah eighty pound yeah I know it's
gonna be good
yeah you go onto the menu here you've
got main courses at 14 yeah 15 pound why
they gone up so expensive spend the
bills bank manager yeah counting and I
the same help me help me how do I do
this they say or again you get a range
prices
eh prices always the bank managers
solution yeah literally down to a bank
manager well he's an [ __ ] okay yeah
it's killing the business I want to look
at restructure in the menu okay making
it a little bit shorter okay tweaking
the portion size alright having less
come back sixty percent our bones come
back but is that forty percent I want to
work on the objective for every customer
comes through that door is to have a
starter yeah her mains and a dessert
okay you wait and see
the turnover treble if you can squeeze
three courses out of them okay
but before we can squeeze anything out
of anybody you need customers and if
they're not coming to us we've got to
take mama Sherry's finger-licking food
to them
got the meatloaf oh yeah ha the ribs got
the chicken that smells amazing and who
better to flaunt it than the mummer
herself don't be shy I'm gonna come to
you since you're not coming to me all
cook fresh and Mama cherry soul food
just around the corner there she's good
a soul food evangelist and she's out to
convert the whole of Brighton just wind
her up and let her go all right don't
forget this time it's on the house like
they're paying you yeah yes I did
there's no doubt that sherita's a
terrific cook but she's employing Brian
to do that job and I'm beginning to
realize she's wasted in the kitchen
just call me mama